We've done turning our request IP into some coordinates--ta-da!
All right. The next step is to draw a map--actually, there are some in between steps.
Before we draw a map let's look at our code again. We actually have two to-do lists.
We said we're going to look up the users coordinates from their IP.
Let's go ahead and do that here-- coords = getcoords(self.request.remoteaddr).
Okay. That should work.
Then we said if we have coordinates, add them to the art.
Right now our art object doesn't take any coordinates.
Let's add an extra property to our art--
coords = db.GeoPtProperty( ).
Again, I found that this existed when I was reading the Google Data Store docs.
Since we're returning a Geo Point here, we can store it in a Geo Point Property.
Again, this is a Google-specific datatype for storing latitude and longitude, and it's super convenient.
Now, I'd like to say required = True, but we already have some art in our database
that doesn't have coordinates. We have a couple options here.
We could either delete all that art and start over,
but being that ASCII Chan is a famous site on the internet, and everybody is using it,
we don't want it to just break. We'll just make this parameter not required.
We'll just have it for future ones.
This is something that comes up all the time when you're developing web applications.
It's kind of backwards compatibility, because you're often adding features,
tweaking your data model. This is one of the reasons things can get a little hairy.
But it's also one of the reasons why the web is really neat,
because you can kind of develop iteratively.
We're adding our coords to our art, and we're going to go down here and say,
if we have coordinates, add them to the art.
That's easy--if coords--basically, if get_coords doesn't return None--
p.coords = coords. Now we're good.
Let's go ahead and try submitting some art in our browser and see if we get an exception.
Reload this. Let's submit a new picture, call this one "cat," enter in a picture of a cat,
and we'll submit this. Okay, I didn't see any exceptions.
Let' me show you something handy we can do in Google App Engine
to make sure this actually submitted properly.
You may notice that when you start up App Engine, it actually mentions in the console
that the admin console is available at this URL or at a URL like this.
Let's go ahead and visit that and let me show you something we can do.
It defaults to the datastore viewer, and it selects all of the entity kinds we have.
We only have one in this drop down.
If I click list entries, I can see all of my entries,
and I can see here is camel and here is cat--my two entries.
I can see that camel doesn't have any coordinates,
because we entered that before we added this feature,
and we can see our cat has map coordinates.
So our feature is working, and that's pretty cool.
There's all sorts of handy stuff in this tool here.
You can check out your indices and all sorts of cool stuff. It's neat to poke around in here.
But, working with the database, this is a particularly handy view.
So let's get out of here for now, and let's move on to the next feature,
which is actually drawing this map.